i'm going to ask you one question
without going too far down a rabbit hole
but i don't know why i'm pr this is
probably crazy it really is
but what do you think happens
if the michael thomas situation does not
get so resolved totally amicably to all
parties here in the next week or so
do you think there's a scintilla of a
chance that the saints would consider
trading him for the right offer
i don't think anything the saints ever
do is accidental
and i think the way they handled michael
thomas a week and a half ago was the
result of a broader strategic effort by
sean payton
to solve this problem once and for all
and
the jeff duncan article in the athletic
i i and look reporters get antsy when i
speak in these terms and sometimes i
care and sometimes i don't i don't think
it was the result of jeff duncan digging
through dumpsters and sneaking around
corners and piecing together threads i
think everything in the jeff duncan
article was given to him
with the idea that he's going to put it
out there that the team wanted it out
there that the team wants everyone to
know the problems they've been having
with michael thomas so we all are at
least
comfortable with the possibility that
they may be taking drastic action with
michael thomas if he doesn't shape up
right now and from peyton's perspective
this is all about bringing this to a
head he's either going to get along
or he's going to be gone
and because i don't think it gets to
this point it never gets to that point
with anyone with the saints we never
hear about these kinds of issues so i
agree with you completely i think
depending upon how michael thomas has
handled the last week and a half
the saints could
again depending upon how he acts how he
conducts himself how he reacts
they they could say we're done i don't
know who wants michael thomas i don't
know who you trade him to at this point
who's going to take on that salary and
the saints would have a cap hit they'd
have to take next year that they would
have to deal with but i think that that
uh you're right that that that's a
possibility and then that opens the door
for antonio brown in new orleans
i think one of the issues right now that
you look at and one of the reasons why
and i forget i looked at this the other
day when i first thought of this
i i i i
the cost for an acquiring team other
than the draft choice compensation i've
got to think that the saints are gonna
are gonna want at least a one for him
um the draft choice compensation is not
is is going to be more of an issue than
the compensation itself because the
saints paid a huge number you know in a
signing bonus first and his salaries are
not really that prohibitive uh when you
think about the guy who has the single
season record for most catches and
man among boys all that stuff
but i do think at the end of the day
we're going to see a period of reckoning
in the next let's say week
um and if you want an absolutely great
receiver but a guy who at times can be
difficult to deal with
um i think though i'll tell you this
mike i think those phone calls are at
least going to be made to mickey loomis
of the saints over the next few days
20 million dollars in cap acceleration
that the saints would take next year if
they trade michael thomas now and you
know the steelers ate 20 million dollars
when they moved on from antonio brown
now with 175 million in cap space that
would be a challenge but
uh i i think that that
it wasn't an accident
i think it's curious that michael thomas
now has a hamstring injury on top of an
ankle injury when they haven't had any
games and he hasn't been practicing
and yeah maybe there's something there
and and and as i said none of this stuff
came out accidentally none of it
happened spontaneously this is all the
result of some broader strategic effort
by sean payton to deal with this issue
and the thing about peyton then we have
to take a break he's a firm believer in
never compounding a mistake by doubling
down if you recognize that something's
not working you deal with it instead of
saying well we paid him all this money
well we may look stupid we may look bad
well we're going to have a harder time
reaching our objectives and our goals if
we have someone on the team that isn't
on board with everything that we're
doing and if we just misread him before
we entrusted him with that money so be
it we learn from it and we move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports